[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
guten abend vorhin ist eine weitere
bundesheer maschine aus kabul in
taschkent gelandet mit rund 220 menschen
an bord der inzwischen fünfte
evakuierungs flug nach angaben der
bundeswehr sind damit seit gestern mehr
als 670 menschen gerettet worden
überhaupt zum flughafen und in den
flughafen hinein zu gelangen ist
weiterhin extrem gefährlich
den geretteten die heute früh in
frankfurt ankam waren die strapazen
anzusehen und die unendliche
erleichterung dara hassanzadeh
endlich wieder da
die gesichter gerettete die ganze
schüssel sind noch ein ohr die man vom
flughafen gehört hat und um das zu
verarbeiten braucht man wirklich paar
tage wegen eines trauerfalls war familie
rutscher in afghanistan sie saßen fest
bis eine e-mail sie an den flughafen
befehligte denn irgendwie schnell
irgendwas mitgenommen haben am flughafen
auch gepäck verloren haben gesagt ist
das egal hauptsache weg her weil ich nun
gedacht habt gut wenn es den kindern gut
geht dann ist es egal was da bleibt oder
was nicht da bleibt trotz deutscher
pässe zunächst kein durchkommen zum
rollfeld in kabul die deutsche presse
helfen dort nicht
also wenn man deutsche präsidentin oder
nicht hat von stehen die amis und sagen
das ist uns egal seine art und der eine
amerikaner hatte mitleid und aus mitleid
hat er uns raus rein gelassen weil er
gemerkt habe beide kinder waren einfach
für ängstlich wir hatten angst und haben
geweint weil es die ganze schüssel
warnschüsse gab es und dann wussten die
nicht was sie machen sollten und
ja es war nicht schön
eine hochzeit war vanessa theiß
reisegrund tage lang hoffte sie auf
nachricht ausgeflogen zu werden
wir haben menschen gesehen die sich
damit haben wir so nahe kommen wie
niemals durch sie haben es geschafft und
mussten familie zurücklassen man kann
nichts tun und man fühlt sich einfach
egoistisch es ist schlimm zu sagen und
man möchte auch nicht egoistisch sein
aber wir mussten es leider tun und ja
man
innerlich weint man trauert man weiß
nicht wie die stunden- oder die tage
vergehen werden dort das ist das halt
jemand keinen moment vorhersagen wie
lange überhaupt noch evakuiert werden
kann ob die taliban sich an absprachen
halten die es geben soll eindrücke von
heute aus kabul von luckwald
bundeswehr sanitäter verarzten eine
junge frau die am ende ihrer kräfte ist
wer es im völligen chaos hierher in den
militärischen sperrbereich des
flughafens geschafft hat kann aufatmen
ein paar meter weiter hinter
stacheldraht warten tausende auf das
ticket dass ihr überleben sichern
vor ihnen us soldaten und afghanische
polizisten die sie mit warnschüssen
energisch zurück drängen hinter ihnen
bewaffnete islamisten die demnächst über
leben und tod in afghanistan entscheiden
werden in sozialen medien sieht man
verzweifelte frauen die um einlass zum
flughafen fliehen eine niederländische
maschine musste ohne passagiere
abfliegen die familien wurden am tor
abgewiesen während sich am himmel über
kabul das unrühmliche ende einer
gescheiterten mission zeigt hat mullah
baradar politischer führer der taliban
die zukunft im ring vor drei jahren
holte ex us präsident den terroristen
aus pakistanischer haft zu
friedensverhandlungen nach doran heute
landete baradar in der alten
afghanischen könig stadt kandahar seine
kampfgenossen sprachen in kabul mit ex
präsident karsai und ex regierungschef
abdullah über eine regierung doch es
gibt auch widerstand fünf demonstranten
zogen durch kabul um für frauenrechte
einzutreten es gibt afghanische frauen
steht auf ihren plakaten
wir lassen uns nicht klein machen sagen
sie nicht wegsperren auch nicht
unterdrücken so ihre mutigen aussagen
sie forderten das recht auf bildung auf
arbeit und sicherheit für frauen
bewaffnete taliban stoppen die frauen
waren aber offenbar unschlüssig wie sie
mit diesem unerwarteten protest umgehen
sollten
brutaler endeten straßenproteste im
ostafghanischen jalalabad wo taliban
gegner mit afghanischen flaggen
demonstrierten am vorabend des
nationalen unabhängigkeitstag
wir werden diese frage nie im stich
lassen die taliban haben sie verboten
und durch ihre weiße emirats fahne
ersetzt sie feuerten plötzlich schüsse
in die menge augenzeugen berichten von
drei toten und zahlreichen verletzten
stefan reker ist uns hinzugeschaltet
leiter des afghanistan büros von caritas
international nahmen terek
guten ausrüstung sie gehören auch zu den
neuankömmlingen die aus afghanistan
ausgeflogen wurden sie wurden letzte
nacht haben sie das geschafft wie war
ihre ausreise erzählen sie uns das
ja das war so ein bisschen
hektisch und ein bisschen neuere kleines
bisschen spannend und und auch sehr
aufregend eigentlich
wurde halb zwölf ortszeit angerufen von
einem von einem anderen deutschen der
sagte also alle deutschen die raus
wollen müssen also ein bestimmtes tor
von flughafen und das war ein sehr
hektisch da hinzukommen wir sind falsche
tor gefahren dann kann man nicht weiter
weil da geschossen wurde das war dann so
warnschüsse dieser soldaten die das tor
gemacht hatten da kann man nicht weiter
weil so viele menschen waren so viele
autos dann muss dann 600 meter laufen
was ich in afghanistan normalerweise
überhaupt nicht mache aus
sicherheitsgründen das war sehr sehr
hektisch kann mir nur eine taliban
patrol ihr vorbei nämlich merkwürdig
beäugt hatten dann kam ich dann dieses
tor da waren wahnsinnig viele menschen
die also wieso eine woge auf die
soldaten der zu strömten die das tor
geschützt hatten da war noch ein paar
amerikanische soldaten da war ich mein
passt denn so geschwenkt und
der amerikanische da hat ja einheitlich
dann aus dieser menge rausgezogen und
dann hinter diese band von afghanischen
amerikanischen soldaten gezogen dann
habe ich dann erstmal so eine halbe
stunde vor diesem tor verbracht und
durchsucht und dann kam noch andere
leute dazu an also afghanen meist
deutsch afghanen amerikaner auf gehören
und wurden wir durchsucht und und
taschen abgetastet und sodann kann man
dann hinter dieses tor irgendwann mal
und dann war erstmal ein großer stein
vom herzen gefallen
und dann ging das mal so weiter hat man
zusammen vier stunden gedauert bis wir
da hinter den flieger standen und dann
endlich im flieger sie haben 15 jahre
ihres lebens und unterbrechungen in
afghanistan verbracht da wird sich in
diese wahnsinnige erleichterungen die
dann in dem moment bei ihnen im herzen
war aber auch schmerz dabei gewesen sein
und sorge um ihre mitarbeiter und vor
allem mitarbeiterinnen die sie jetzt
zurück lassen
jaha genau also eigentlich wollte ich
gar nicht weg ich wurde gebieten von
meiner geschäftsstelle wegzufahren
versicherungsgründen haftungsgründen und
so weiter und so fort aber auch
sicherheitsgründe weil ich als als
ausländer natürlich auch eine
sicherheitsrisiko darstelle für das büro
von caritas international in afghanistan
und für meine nationalen kolleginnen
kollegen und dann bin ich halt
ausgereist
mit dem wissen dass wir diese kollegen
jetzt erstmal zurück lassen und jetzt
werde ich hier im büro in freiburg von
caritas international arbeiten und alles
dran setzen dass es den kollegen gut
geht dass sie sicher sind wir müssen
verschiedene optionen durchgehen da
müssen wahrscheinlich auch
einzellösungen geschaffen werden für für
bestimmte kollegen diese lösung für
andere kolleginnen diese lösungen und
wir werden zusehen dass die alle sicher
sind und bleiben
darüber hinaus gehende frage ist wie es
überhaupt jetzt mit den
hilfsorganisationen mit
entwicklungszusammenarbeit in
afghanistan
weitergehen wird ist es ja auch noch gar
nicht klar ob weiterhin geld fließen
wird im moment ist das erstmal gestoppt
von ihren erfahrungen her glauben sie
man kann die taliban mit geld
beeinflussen
also ich habe ja selber schon unter den
taliban 10 sag ich mal gearbeitet in den
neunzigerjahren anfang 2000 habe anfang
der 2000er jahre klar sind taliban auch
an hilfsprogrammen interessiert an
entwicklungsprogrammen programm der
humanitären hilfe und da kann man
sicherlich auch was drin ich will nicht
sagen dass man die unter druck setzen
kann und soll das ist der falsche ansatz
da muss man viel diskutieren viel reden
oder dann geht auch was
ich halte den falschen ansatz da drohen
auszusprechen ich denke da kann man mit
ein bisschen subtilität müssen durch
diplomatie wir viel erreichen auch
gerade was im bereich frauen arbeit geht
also einmal frauen die mit uns im büro
arbeiten in den hilfsorganisationen aber
auch was frauen als hilfsempfänger im
betrifft da kann man viel viel drehen
wenn man mit denen mit diesen leuten
vernünftig redet und ein bisschen geduld
hat und ein bisschen hippie mattiert
recker sie haben eine lange und und
aufregende reise hinter sich und sind
auch müde ich weiß ich danke für das
gespräch und gerne bei nächster
gelegenheit und dann reden wir nochmal
ausführlich ja auch wie das jetzt mit
entwicklungsarbeit in afghanistan
weitergehen kann danke
ich danke ihnen für das
gespräch aufgezeichnet
und während die evakuierungen noch im
vollen gange sind mit allen
unwägbarkeiten
müssen sich die zuständigen minister in
berlin unangenehmen fragen stellen denn
auch die parlamentarier vor allem die
der opposition wollen wissen warum die
rettung so spät anlief warum nicht schon
vor wochen die noch im land befindlichen
afghanischen ortskräfte raus geholt
wurden warum gab es nicht viel früher
beherzten pragmatismus statt
bürokratischer hürden gab es ein
abstimmungs hick hack zwischen
außenminister innenminister und
verteidigungsministerin und vor allem
wie konnte es zu dieser fatalen
fehleinschätzung der lage kommen die nun
als erklärung für alles genannt wird aus
berlin frankfurt
antreten im verteidigungsausschuss es
geht um die katastrophe von kabul von
der ministerin ein kurzes statement nur
abgelesen formelhaft es ist ganz klar
die bundeswehr wird so lange wie möglich
so schnell wie möglich so viele menschen
wie möglich dort rausholen kritische
fragen dann hinter verschlossenen türen
die sitzung geheim die opposition nicht
überzeugt
in der tat werden wir danach politisch
das aufarbeiten und ich schließe nicht
aus dass dann auch für den ein oder
anderen minister und die ministerin das
ende eingeläutet wird inzwischen hat die
bundeswehr eine luftbrücke eingerichtet
immerhin mit transportmaschinen fliegt
sie menschen aus kabul heraus die in
afghanistan um ihr leben fürchten müssen
es ist allerdings bisher nicht so
dass auf den kontrollpunkten dies rund
um den flughafen gibt irgendeine
anweisung vorliegt dass auch ortskräfte
von uns oder von anderen staaten an den
flughafen durchgelassen werden viele
befürchten deshalb dass die taliban
verzweifelte menschen nun als faustpfand
missbrauchen es ist zurzeit nichts mehr
ausgeschlossen weil die untätigkeit der
letzten wochen und monate die
bundesrepublik in eine situation
gebracht hat in der wir massiv
erpressbar sind uns auch erpresst werden
von den taliban und das ist einfach nur
furchtbar es geht aber nicht nur um geld
auch der politische preis den die
taliban für die rettung der menschen
verlangen bisher kaum absehbaren
kanzlerin merkel ging zuletzt davon aus
dass deutschland versuchen wird und
10.000 personen aus kabul rauszuholen
wobei sie bei dieser zahl nicht nur von
orts kräften sprach sondern auch von
menschenrechtsaktivisten und besonders
gefährdeten frauen die zu deutschen
stellen kontakt hatten selbst sollen es
tatsächlich schaffen sollte sie alle
noch auszufliegen und es am ende nicht
sehen sondern 20.000 menschen wären das
wäre innenpolitisch wohl kein problem
noch nicht mal die afg ist gegen die
aktuelle evakuierungsaktion bevor die
bundesregierung wie auch die anderen
eu-länder angst haben ist dass das
afghanische desaster demnächst dann zu
massiven flüchtlingsbewegungen und führt
wie seinerzeit in folge des syrien
kriegs anne gellinek berichtet
sie sind aus der afghanischen armee
weggelaufen als die taliban vorrückten
und nun zu fuß unterwegs seit
zweieinhalb monaten von afghanistan
durch iran haben sie es ins türkische
grenzgebiet geschafft
die türkische polizei jagt uns wenn sie
uns kriegt schlagen sie uns nehmen uns
unser geld und unsere handys ab
ein kleines grüppchen afghanischer
flüchtlinge auf dem weg nach westen
vorboten einer vielleicht neuen
flüchtlingsbewegung aus afghanistan es
sind bilder die die eu-innenminister
fürchten weil sie europa erneut spalten
in ihrer video konferenz fordert
luxemburg quoten für flüchtlinge aus
afghanistan
österreich dagegen will keinen einzigen
afghanen mehr aufnehmen die eu
innenkommissarin formuliert europas
minimalkonsens
wir müssen vermeiden dass menschen sich
auf gefährliche reisen begeben und als
illegale migranten an unseren grenzen
auftauchen wir sollten nicht warten bis
sie an unseren grenzen stehen wir müssen
ihnen vorher helfen bevor bat die
nachbarländer von afghanistan sollen
flüchtlinge aufnehmen so der plan der eu
damit diese sich nicht auf den weg nach
europa machen die eu wird dafür zahlen
klingt gut aber ist das realistisch
pakistan hat bereits 1,4 millionen
afghanen aufgenommen und jede woche
kommen 30.000 neue hinzu iran beherbergt
auch schon jetzt zwei millionen afghanen
in der türkei haben 3,5 millionen syrer
plus 500 1000 afghanen zuflucht gefunden
die türkische regierung hat bereits
abgelehnt weitere flüchtlinge
aufzunehmen und baut an einer mauer zum
iran trotzdem träumen einige europäer
weiter von fernen lagern in die sie
unerwünschte flüchtlinge sogar
abschieben könnten österreich schickt
weiter
nach europa rechtlichen möglichkeiten ab
dort muss klar sein dass es alternativen
gibt das wir abschiebezentren schaffen
in den nachbarländern afghanistan noch
haben weniger afghanische flüchtlinge
europas außengrenzen erreicht die eu
scheint wild entschlossen dass das auch
bei einer neuen flüchtlingswelle so
bleibt
und jetzt macht erstmal hans wolff
weiter mit den nachrichten in haiti ist
die zahl der todesopfer vier tage nach
dem erdbeben weiter gestiegen auf fast
2000 etwa 10.000 menschen seien verletzt
halten die lokalen behörden mit viele
überlebende warten immer noch auf
dringend notwendige unterstützung in den
vergangenen tagen erschwerte der
tropensturm grace mit heftigem regen und
überschwemmungen die such und
rettungsarbeiten nach unicef-angaben
sind 1,2 millionen menschen darunter
fast die hälfte kinder von der
katastrophe betroffen
wenn sie den menschen helfen wollen sie
können beim aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe spenden unter der
bekannten kontonummer mit dem stichwort
zdf nothilfe haiti die bahn de 65 104
106 100 104 106 100 weitere
informationen finden sie unter spenden
punkt zdf de oder internet text auf
seite 8 190
in potsdam ist das neue europäische
zentrum für jüdische theologie an der
universität eröffnet worden es ist das
erste jüdische gotteshaus in der stadt
nach dem holocaust
beim festakt würdigte bundespräsident
steinmeier das religions- zentrum als
ausbildungsstätte für rabbinerinnen und
rabbinern als geschenk für unser ganzes
land zugleich zeigte er sich über den
anhaltenden antisemitismus gesorgt
dieser sei unerträglich so steinmeier
der zinssatz bei
steuernachforderungen und erstattungen
muss neu geregelt werden das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat den
bisherigen satz von sechs prozent
jährlich gekippt also angesichts des
niedrigen zinsniveaus nicht mehr zu
rechtfertigen
der neue zinssatz muss nun vom
gesetzgeber festgelegt werden und kommt
dann auch schon rückwirkend ab 2009 10
zur anwendung
zur krone lage in deutschland
das robert koch institut meldet 8300 24
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden das
sind
3328 mehr als vor einer woche
22 todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
tage incidents liegt jetzt bei
40,8
die zahlen werden bald wohl noch viel
mehr steigen mit allen risiken die das
in erster linie für ungeimpfte
beinhaltet zumal man inzwischen weiß
dass dieses virus heftige spätfolgen
entwickeln können auch bei jüngeren und
auch bei infizierten die einen eher
milden verlauf hatten longo wird ist ein
noch ziemlich unberechenbares und
unerforschtes phänomen dass die
ärztinnen und ärzte die damit
konfrontiert werden vor entsprechende
probleme stellt die deutsche
gesellschaft für lungenkrankheiten und
beatmungsmedizin hat heute erstmals
medizinische leitlinien vorgestellt für
den umgang mit longo witt und costco
bild denn genau so schwierig ist die
therapie von kogit patienten die lange
auf der intensivstation lagen und danach
in reha müsse auch da gibt es noch viel
unbekanntes medizinisches thema
berichtet britta spiekermann
station für physikalische medizin und
rehabilitation in der berliner charité
erste auffangstation für menschen nach
langer intensivmedizinischer behandlung
früher war hier vor allem patienten nach
unfällen oder operationen jetzt
ausschließlich auf der station nachsorge
bei schwersten cupid 19 verläufen nach
künstlicher beatmung
morgendliche visite frau dr saison mit
ihrem team dies die zuständige
oberärztin eine der expertinnen in
deutschland für die behandlung von cobit
19 spätfolgen patienten die ganz von
vorne anfangen müssen ein mühsamer weg
zurück ins leben
[Musik]
und der
anstrengenden ort
sie haben schlecht geschlafen hören sie
gleich noch mal die ist es mit der mit
der luft botschaften wie es sich an die
welt kann dazu setzt ohne dass die
luftnot haben ja
nur drei stunden ohne sauerstoff und das
hat funktioniert
gehört man beobachtet bei den patienten
nach diesem langen bearbeitungszeiten
schwerste funktions defizite die
patienten sehen sich selber als
vergreist an denen es nicht möglich sich
allein im bett aufzurichten sich auf zu
setzen also es ist eine erhebliche
kraftlosigkeit eingetreten durch
muskelabbau im wesentlichen gab es vor
der pandemie schon einen mangel an
plätzen in der reha ist es jetzt eine
akute not besonders bei postkarten ist
das krankheitsbild komplex zudem oft
noch neuland ende 2020 fühlt sich
norbert grobecker krank aus einem
simplen husten wird plötzlich luftnot
intensivstation ein monat künstliches
koma grobecker überlebt nur knapp ein
therapeut dehnt seine lunge von außen
körperlich und seelisch muss der
60-jährige wieder vertrauen gewinnen
seinen damaligen zustand kann er heute
immer noch nicht fassen ich konnte nicht
mal kommunizieren konnte mit meiner
familie
keinen kontakt aufnehmen das erfolgt ist
nur über die flieger über die ärzte und
wie gesagt auch ein top team und wir
sagten ja auch sehr dankbar und auch die
ärzte ja ich dann einmal zu durchhalten
animieren weil irgendwann ist gefangen
in seinem eigenen körper
auch weniger schwere verläufe können zu
erheblichen spätfolgen führen eine
herausforderung für reha kliniken
ambulanzen für das gesamte
gesundheitssystem
meines erachtens wäre sinnvoll einen
gemeinsamen anfangspunkt zu schaffen im
sinne von costco witt ambulanzen oder
vielleicht auch teilstationären
strukturen von denen aus den patienten
gezielt in die bereiche überwiesen
werden in denen sie dann endgültig
behandelt werden können die symptomatik
ist vielfältig lungen funktionsstörungen
müdigkeit konzentrationsproblemen die
wir ja oh geht davon aus dass in
deutschland rund
350.000 menschen an den spätfolgen von
coop 19 leiden könnten ein noch
unterschätztes problem mit potenzial zur
nächsten großen volkskrankheit
das trauma das die flutopfer erlitten
haben die bilder die sie nicht mehr aus
dem kopf bekommen der verlust so vieler
persönlicher dinge das lässt sich mit
geld natürlich nicht heilen aber
zumindest würde es den wiederaufbau
erleichtern die bundesregierung hat
heute ein fluthilfe form beschlossen für
die hochwassergebiete in nordrhein
westfalen und rheinland pfalz insgesamt
30 milliarden damit sollen vor allem
schäden bezahlt werden die nicht von
privaten versicherungen abgedeckt sind
zu den vielen gebäuden die zerstört sind
oder auf lange zeit nicht nutzbar
gehören auch schulen in nordrhein
westfalen war heute erster schultag nach
den ferien mehr als 170 schulen sind
dort vom hochwasser betroffen dominik
müller russ l berichtet aus greife
endlich geht es wieder los endlich
wieder mathe bio englisch draußen direkt
vor dem städtischen gymnasium in
schleiden noch immer autowracks und
schuttberge doch drinnen soll normalität
herrschen so viel wie möglich haben sie
ganz bewusst entschieden
die gefahr besteht ja immer dass man
wenn man das als einen echten
tagesordnungspunkt sag ich mal am ersten
schultag
einbaut besprechen die katastrophe dass
man dann auch schüler in ungünstigen
situationen bringt die möglicherweise
jetzt nicht vor der klasse über ihre
belastung sprechen wollen die sicherlich
im informellen rahmen mit den lehrern
sprechen wollen mit mitschüler mit den
sehr gut befreundet sind natürlich
tauschen sich die schüler darüber aus
bei ihnen ist nur die sporthalle
zerstört und die heizungsanlage manche
schülerinnen und schüler hier aber haben
alles verloren womöglich sogar
angehörige 30 menschen sind im landkreis
gestorben schule kommt nun eine ganz
neue funktion zu einfach nur da sein
ich finde diese dieses gefühl von
gemeinsamkeit das hilft einfach sehr
viel und ich glaube auch dass das vor
einigen betroffenen schülern hilft dass
nicht alles immer jetzt präsent das
zuhause ist das thema genug präsent und
ich glaube es hilft einfach wenn man
jetzt in der schule ist dass man
abschalten kann und weiß ich bin nicht
alleine aber ich habe was anderes ein
paar hundert meter weiter in der
förderschule und in der katholischen
grundschule ist man noch nicht zu weit
hier kann der schulbetrieb erst nächste
woche starten zu groß sind noch die
schäden einer milliardenschweren
hilfsfonds hat die bundesregierung heute
beschlossen 30 milliarden euro für den
wiederaufbau von wohnhäusern und
unternehmen von straßen brücken und
schienen und von öffentlichen gebäuden
wie eben schule in schleiden rechnen sie
damit dass der schaden für die stadt
unterm strich bei 300 millionen euro
liegen wird die zeit drängt nun muss es
schnell und einfach gehen
große antragsverfahren noch
fördermitteln die wir ja eine
vergangenheit kennen so eine art
wettbewerbsverfahren unter den kommunen
das können wir nicht brauchen wir
brauchen möglich antrags los
fördermittel die uns zur verfügung
gestellt werden wo wir auch spielraum
haben entscheidungsspielraum wo setzen
wir es zuerst sein ob in der schule in
der kita da wo es am dringendsten
benötigt wird da möchten wir es auch
einsetzen und das möchten wir nicht
vorgegeben bekommen am städtischen
gymnasium sind sie froh dass sie heute
ins neue schuljahr starten konnten
sensibel und so normal wie möglich
heute war ein weiteres mal auto gipfel
mit bundeskanzlerin merkel bei der video
konferenz ging es auch ums geld um einen
milliardenschweren zukunft von stefanie
berit für welche zukunftspläne ist
dieser fonds gedacht der fond ist vor
allem auf den wandel in der
zulieferindustrie ausgerichtet dazu
machte der bund heute eine finanzspritze
von einer milliarde euro für die
nächsten vier jahre startklar um
regionale strategien und netzwerke für
den wissensaustausch zu fördern sowie
die digitalisierung voranzutreiben
hilfe beim wandel zur e mobilität
brauchen vor allem die kleinen
familiengeführten zulieferbetriebe im
ländlichen raum rund 70 automobil
cluster gibt es in deutschland und 20
bis 30 davon sind
im zuge der transformation akut
gefährdet wie etwa in saarland oder in
süd fest fallen hier müssen mitarbeiter
umgeschult und produktion verändert
werden das kostet geld viel geld dass
sich die großen börsennotierten firmen
wie schaeffler oder conti günstig am
kapitalmarkt besorgen können die kleinen
aber eben nicht deren eigenkapitaldecke
es dünn und im corona ja vielfach
dahingeschmolzen
sie haben schwierigkeiten das kapital
aufzubringen dass man für die hohen
investitionen braucht hier an der börse
seien anleger heute vor allem die
riesigen herausforderungen vor denen die
branche noch steht autotitel zählten
gegen den trend zu den verlierern im dax
eine milliarde euro das klingt nach viel
geld gemessen am 100 milliarden umsatz
der deutschen zulieferindustrie ist es
dann aber doch eher ein bruchteil ob der
von tatsächlich ausreicht um die zukunft
finanzieren fraglich stattfindet vielen
dank
im süden frankreichs sind beim bisher
schwersten waldbrand in diesem jahr zwei
menschen gestorben und mehr als 20
personen leicht verletzt worden das
meldet der südfranzösische
verwaltungsbezirk war und 1200
einsatzkräfte waren im hinterland von
santa fe im einsatz 7000 hektar land
sind bereits verbrannt und 10.000
menschen einwohner und touristen mussten
auf notunterkünfte ausweichen
und jetzt die zahlen vom lotto am
mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr
7 22
25 27
43 48
superzahl 6 und weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto zdf de und im zdf
text auf seite 55 7
das war es von uns gleich folgt ein
auslandsjournal spezial zur lage in
afghanistan
unter anderen mit einem bericht über
mutige frauen jetzt um ihr leben
fürchten müssen
gegen 0.45 gibt es dann unsere heutige
update mit anna maria schuck und hier
übernehmen morgen bettina schausten und
brause auf wiedersehen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
sturmtief luciano ist weiter nach
nordosten gezogen und hat die schwüle
hitze verdrängt 40 grad gab es deswegen
heute eigentlich nur noch hier richtung
ural ähnlich heiß wurde es auch auf der
iberischen halbinsel mit 38 grad an
diesen temperaturen ändert sich auch
morgen über tage wenig sie sehen die 40
grad die gibt es ja wirklich nur noch
richtung kaspisches meer am mittelmeer
liegen die temperaturen bei 30 bis 35
grad aber in ganz mittel- nord- und
westeuropa liegen die temperaturen doch
bei recht niedrigen 15 bis 20 grad das
allerdings wird sich ändern denn hier
von der iberischen halbinsel wird sich
die wärme bis sonntag über südfrankreich
weiter in richtung nordosten verschieben
und dann können wir am sonntag zumindest
mal vorübergehend in deutschland wieder
30 grad haben heute nacht wird erst mal
kühl in bayern sinken die werte auf 11 9
grad sonst geht's auf 16 bis 12 grad
runter es gibt viele wolken und ab und
zu auch ein bisschen regen im norden und
im westen und auch morgen ist für viele
eher noch ein trüber tag mit hier und da
etwas regen freundlicher sieht es aus
und der nordsee und am nachmittag auch
in süddeutschland die temperaturen sind
ziemlich verhalten sie liegen zwischen
18 und maximal 23 grad und am freitag
gibt es dann noch kräftigeren regen im
äußersten norden das ist aber immer mehr
nach bei temperaturen von 19 bis 25 grad
der samstag wird ein schöner augusttag
aber am sonntag kommen dann von westen
neue gewitter heran